on plaisante plus du tout parce que ça
m'a particulièrement choqué des
étudiants en sociologie aurait tenu
pendant plusieurs mois des conversations
racistes envers d'autres étudiants et
professeurs sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est le 13 heures de france 2 france 2
qui nous raconte cette histoire des
commentaires à caractère raciste des
émoticônes dégradants en dessous de
photos d'étudiants de professeurs noir
ces messages échangés via les réseaux
sociaux ces étudiants de la faculté de
sociologie de maistre est choquée en ont
été les victimes
on traite de saint jean de bonnot boc a
peur de cette dotation auprès de pont
pour ne pas qu'on teste péage de parfums
parce que tu pues mais c'est
inadmissible on n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre
à l'origine de ces messages un groupe
d'étudiants de la même promotion qui
avait créé il ya quelques mois un groupe
privé sur facebook la faculté de
lorraine a immédiatement condamné ses
activi à son compte twitter annonçant
l'ouverture d'une enquête en interne
avant d'effectuer un signalement auprès
du procureur de la république donc une
ouverture dans une enquête en interne
et je rappelle évidemment que le racisme
est un délit et donc là effectivement
l'université à porter auprès du
procureur cette affaire en justice
puisque bien sûr que c'est un délit
qu'est ce que vous en pensez damien de
cette histoire sont des étudiants en
sociologie dont on se dit qu'ils sont
normalement particulièrement éclairé et
qu'il ne devrait pas y avoir ce genre de
truc complètement abject alors
effectivement alors même si ces messages
proviennent de deux ou trois étudiants à
selon la direction de l'université ce
sont des faits extrêmement graves qui
sont très préoccupants mais qui reflète
j'ai envie de dire la société
malheureusement de nombreuses personnes
issues de l'immigration sont
quotidiennement victimes de genre de
problème et je suis persuadé que si on
faisait un reportage chaque jour de
l'année sur des faits de racisme dans
des entreprises complètement différente
on y arriverait parce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est
intégrer il y à du racisme
il faut le combattre mais
malheureusement voilà ce que vous me
dites pas ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
c'est intégré comme si c'était une
donnée à laquelle il fallait faire c'est
clair c'est terrible enfin ludivine dit
moss pose maintenant il faut
certainement pas se laisser faire vous
voyez la libération de la parole à
laquelle on assiste depuis des mois déjà
eh ben le permet justement de pouvoir y
mettre en lumière des faits aussi
innommable que ceux-ci il faut le savoir
moi je trouve que le président a très
bien réagi le président de l'université
j'ai pas envie qu'on commençait à
minorer en disant oui avec eux deux
trois personnes dans le groupe par ce
même moment 1 c'est trop un règlement
mais d'abord ils étaient bien plus
nombreux
que cela mais c'est une réalité qui est
là qui existe qui l attend en france et
qui est sous-estimé parce qu'on a un
idéal républicain de ce qu'est l'école
de ski et l'université et ça se passe et
ça se passe tous les jours
est ce que ce n'est pas surprenant
pardonnez moi mais moi je suis surprise
par le fait qu'il s'agisse de jeunes
gens nous on imagine toujours que
peut-être c'est une arrière-garde une
vieille génération qui n'aurait pas
évolué et que peut-être le racisme ce
serait plutôt le fait de personnes âgées
et là en l'occurrence des jeunes éduqués
à l'université ça vous semble pas
surprenant à ce que c'est quoi les
réseaux sociaux merci voilà ce sont les
mêmes qu'on retrouve sur les réseaux
sociaux valérie moi je m'en prends tous
les jours mais plein la tronche des des
messages ainsi que ce soit des messages
privés ou même en dessous de nos photos
des photos qu'on peut partager
il ya toujours des choses comme ça qui
malheureusement apparaissent mais qui
sont condamnables il faut surtout que
les personnes qui regardent les z'igues
ce genre d' insulte raciste le sache
il encourt jusqu'à six mois de prison et
plus de 22000 euros damende il ya deux
choses d'abord il ya la libération des
pulsions individuel ce sont des
individus même s'ils sont en groupe
et puis ça ça va de pair avec la montée
de la violence avec le communautarisme
et puis il ya la deuxième chose il ya le
paradoxe c'est à dire que maintenant sur
tous les plateaux de télé tout le monde
fait extrêmement attention on n'a plus
le droit de blaguer sur certains sujets
il ya un contraste très terrible entre
ce paradoxe où il ya plus d'humour on
mesure les raconter il ya une pulsion
morbide qui arrivent et l'autre côté de
racisme et comme derrière on comprend
pas pourquoi donc ça veut dire que la
société elle est malade en ce moment
deux sociétés qui se crispe qui est et
qui est
mais j'ai le pire en l koala exactement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez déjà que
l'on conditionne aussi nos jeunes au
racisme du a dû aux informations à la
télé sur toutes les chaînes aux radios
web par exemple vous donne un exemple on
dit toujours l individu d'origine
guadeloupéenne marocaine a commis un
meurtre
on a plus de doute maintenant d'un
dividende hitman individu est toujours
un appui laisser veille quand j'ai ça
m'arrive défago au restaurant j'entends
des gens parler à table et ils disent
non mais t'as vu c'est gênant mais il a
eu trente six coups de couteau il a été
assassiné l'autre personne en face à ben
je suis sûr c'est un noir ou un arabe
non mais tout le temps tout est ce que
je suis je suis d'accord avec toi c'est
bien sûr notamment sur les informations
où il ya une pointe du doigt l'origine
de la grève faire pareil c'est terrible
effectivement ça vise à stigmatiser une
communauté
une autre en attendant c'est un élément
d'information il ne faut pas le taire si
ces quatre quarts d'origine arménienne
il faut le dire aussi
donc voilà après c'est un élément
d'information de savoir d'où il provient
mais je suis d'accord ça part et ça
participe à la stigmatisation dès que
vous en pensez sur ce sujet que moi je
trouve extrêmement douloureux
extrêmement inquiétant vraiment mais et
douloureux encore plus qu'inquiétant
combat parce que c'est le reflet d'une
société qui va mal quand malheureusement
les jeunes on arrive à ce genre de
dérives